[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, friends.
Welcome back to the last
data science hangout of 2022.
I hope you all are
having a great week.
If you're joining us for
the first time today,
thanks for coming to hang out.
I'm Rachael.
It's so nice to meet you.
I see a bunch of people
in the waiting room,
so maybe I'll just press the
meet-all button in one second
here.
But this is an open space
for the whole data science
community to connect and chat
about data-science leadership,
questions you're
facing, and getting
to learn about what's going
on in the world of data
across different industries.
So together, we're all
dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment
for everybody.
And we love to
hear from everyone,
no matter your level of
experience or your area of work
as well.
So there's always three ways
that you can ask questions here
in this space and also
provide your perspective.
You can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to put a
little star next to it
if you want me to
read it, if you're
in a coffee shop, or
your dogs barking,
or something like that.
And then third, we
also have a Slido link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And I bet Hanna is
sharing that in the chat
here in just a second.
If this is your
first hangout today,
I thought it would
be nice to maybe
have you say hi by putting
a one into the chat.
And if you've been
here before, put a two.
For those who have
been here before,
many times we'd love to all
help welcome you in as well.
And so just to let
everybody know,
we do share the recordings of
each session up to the Posit
YouTube.
So you can always go
back and rewatch or find
helpful resources.
We do also have a LinkedIn
group for the hangout
too if it helps you
connect with each other.
One more thing on the topic
of recordings and resources,
I am hoping to take a quick poll
from the community this week
on what has worked
well for you, what
hasn't, and any suggestions
you have for next year.
So we'll share that link in
the chat in a second too.
But I so appreciate
the thoughtful feedback
that so many of you
have provided already,
not only in the survey, but
throughout the year as well.
So with all of that, thank
you so much for being here.
Let's jump in.
This is the first
time my co-host
is in the same building as
me, not in the same room.
But so happy to be joined by my
co-host today J.J. Allaire, CEO
and founder of Posit, I throw in
the formerly known as RStudio.
Thanks for joining us, J.J.
Absolutely.
I'd love to have you
introduce yourself and share
a bit about your
background, and maybe
also let us know something you
like to do outside of work too.
OK.
Well, very briefly, I obviously
do lots of software engineering
and product development now.
But when I was younger, I
studied political science.
And I got very interested
in data analysis.
But I took a deep
detour from that
and got into writing
software and worked on lots
of different software products.
And I think it was 11 or 12
years ago, I became aware of R.
And I was actually looking
for opportunities to work
on open-source software.
And I thought it was
tremendously cool
that the thing that got
me interested in software
in the first place, and the
first thing I wanted to do,
which was data analysis,
had this really, really
vital open-source project
associated with it.
So I said let me
get involved with R.
And then I've been doing that
at RStudio and now at Posit for,
I think, it's been
11 or 12 years.
So I started the company.
And I worked on the RStudio IDE.
And then I worked quite
a bit on Markdown.
I'm a little bit on Shiny, some
stuff related to TensorFlow.
And then about two
or three years ago,
I started a new
project called Quarto
which was a reimagining
of R Markdown,
both in terms if we
had to do it all over
again from the beginning,
what would we do?
But also to make R Markdown
multi-language to make it
so it could work for R,
and Python, and Julia,
and JavaScript, and really
make it available for anyone
who is doing scientific
communication
or doing data analysis of
any kind in any language.
So that's what I've been
working on and continuing
to work on now.
And I got my hands in lots
of other different projects
here at RStudio too.
And then, what do I like
to do outside of work?
I like to play
Magic the Gathering.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So I'd love to
ask you, what made
you so interested in
open source initially?
It was really that
the first couple
big software projects I worked
on were proprietary software.
And I found it disappointing
that proprietary software
products get very tied up with
the company that sponsors them.
And the fate of that company
and the other products
that company might offer, or who
that company gets acquired by,
really end up affecting
the fate of the projects.
And I also found that
some proprietary software
is either cheap or
free or low cost,
but there's a certain impediment
to adoption associated
with the price, that
as a creative person
I want my work to be available
as broadly as possible.
So both, it's make the work
available to as many people as
possible, but also
there's a dimension
of the durability of the work.
Is the work going to be around
in 30 years or 40 years?
What are the things
that would make it not?
So that that's what made
open source appealing to me.
I'm seeing a lot of love for
Quarto in the chat right now.
But while we wait just a
minute here for questions
to come in from
everybody, I'm also
curious, what are
you most excited
about at Posit in
the next year ahead?
The next year?
Well, it's going to be
related to Quarto to,
of course, because that's what
I'm spending all my time on.
I would say that the thing
I'm excited about is--
and you can see
some of this work
in the visual editor
that's in RStudio.
But we recognize that Quarto is
really a powerful and flexible
and actually easy to use
for certain subset of users
who are very technical
and very motivated.
But we actually want to make
Quarto available more broadly.
And so working on tooling
that lets technical people
collaborate with non-technical
people over documents,
and also lets some less
technical people participate
in using Quarto, are
the things that I'm
focused on for the next year.
And I'm excited to see
those getting realized.
Awesome.
Sam, I see you put a
question to the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, I just
wanted to see what
your thoughts were on AI
tools like ChatGPT and GitHub
Copilot.
Yeah, I think that I'm a
little concerned that companies
are rushing these things out
in the sort of excitement
and novelty of them
and have not thought
through the implications
of their broader use.
Something like ChatGPT
is not really like--
the creators of it don't
have full control of it.
You can see that
in the safeguards
that they attempted to
put in, but then you
can circumvent the
safeguards and get
it to tell you things that
it's not supposed to tell you.
So I think things that
are happening in AI,
and generative AI
specifically, are exciting.
But I feel technology companies
and technologists sometimes
feel like, we should
do this because we can,
or we should do this because
it's cool, and haven't thought
about the broader social,
political, economic
implications.
So I feel certainly exciting
to see us come up with AI
that is that
powerful, but I think
we're going a little too fast.
That would be my position.
Thank you.
Libby, I saw you also asked
a question in the chat.
You want to jump in?
Sure.
I was wondering,
because I've been
doing a lot of
retrospection lately,
in hindsight, what is
one of the best decisions
that you ever made for
your career your education?
I would say the best
decision that I ever
made is probably that--
and this, actually, has
a lot of commonality
with talking to a lot of
people about their careers.
I think when I was
about in my late 30s,
I had been involved in
both developing software
and also starting companies.
And I really
learned about myself
that the company part
of things, management
and the entrepreneurship, I
really did not like at all.
I did not like it.
I didn't enjoy it.
I didn't.
And so I said, I'm happy to be
involved in starting companies,
but I'm absolutely not
going to do that part.
And I'm going to have to find a
partner or other people who are
excited about doing that part.
And what I really want to
do is focus on engineering
and product development.
And it's very easy
as a company founder
to get pulled into all
kinds of other things.
And that's what happened
to me the first two times.
And just being super clear
about that and saying,
I won't even do it, unless I
can satisfy this condition.
So I think that's pretty broadly
applicable in that a lot of us
accumulate a lot of
responsibility in our careers.
And some of it is
necessary and important
for a given role or company.
But then, eventually,
being clear about what do
I really like to do
and really want to do,
and what do I feel like I should
do or what is put upon me.
I know a lot of people now,
who are in their 40s, who
have actually managed dozens
of people and are like, yeah,
I don't really want
to do that anymore.
I don't ever want to have
anyone work for me anymore.
So I'm going to be
really clear about that.
And I'm going to walk in.
And people are going to
try to give me people.
They're going to try
to make me a manager.
And I'm not going to do it.
So I think it applies
pretty broadly.
But just knowing yourself
and setting pretty rigid
constraints about what you're
willing to do in the workplace
and not.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
That's something
that's definitely
come up quite a few times in
this space too, in that jump
to management and then you
lose out on the technical side.
Yeah, it's a hard one.
And everybody's different.
And both can be
really rewarding.
I know a lot of people who
find management very rewarding.
But I know a lot of people
who find it really alienating.
I see a few anonymous
questions that came in too,
so I want to make sure
I jump over there.
And one was, will Posit
work to make Python
as enjoyable to use as R?
Well, we have a different,
special relationship with R
in that we have the tidyverse.
We've defined this
sort of system
within the system that's
totally internally, hopefully,
as much as possible, totally
internally consistent
and is really well
tooled end to end.
I don't know that we'll
ever be able to have
that relationship to
Python because Python,
they're just so vast.
And people are piecing together
so many different things
from so many different places.
So I think we'll
make contributions.
We're definitely
focused right now
on doing Quarto for Python
and Shiny for Python.
I don't actually think that
any company is big enough
to do for Python what
we sort of did for R.
So I think we'll make it
more pleasurable in places.
But I don't I don't
know that it's
going to be anything like
what we've done with R.
Yu, I see you put a question
into the chat a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in next?
Sure.
Hi, J.J. Actually my
question is kind of piggyback
on what you just said.
So R as a programming language
is almost 30 years old.
And R versus Python
is an eternal topic.
So where do you see R
in the next ten years?
So actually, R is
even over 40 years
old, if you count S,
which is its precursor.
I think what we're
trying to do with R,
and you can see a lot of
the stuff that we've done,
and maybe it's not
all super visible yet,
but some of the
things we've done
in the tidyverse
in the last year
have been focused on making
error messages much better.
And so I feel R
has the potential
to go over the transom from
people who do not program,
do not think of
themselves as programmers,
have not programmed,
to do successful going
to code first data science.
I think R is actually pretty
uniquely positioned to do that.
And I feel we are just
getting started with that.
So the people today, they may
use Excel or SPSS or Tableau.
They're doing data analysis,
but they're actually not
able to ask and answer all
the questions they should.
I see R fitting right
in that spot of the best
way for someone who thinks
themself, I'm a biologist,
I'm an economist, but I need
to answer difficult questions
about data.
So I see R getting better
and better and better
in that vector.
And that's certainly
where we're putting
our time at least in the
tidyverse team right now.
So we're now getting
confessions into Slido too.
Someone said, so this
is a confession and also
a call for suggestions.
I love dplyr Shiny,
and R, but I'm
switching to Python
simply because it's
listed in a lot more jobs and
gives a better starting point
for a possible career change
in other areas of programming.
So what would you advise
for someone in my position?
Well, there are a lot of ideas
in R that you're familiar with.
And then some of
those are carried over
to different
libraries in Python.
So you can try to find
the places in Python
and adopt the projects.
There's definitely some of the--
I think Plot 9, and I
think it's, like, "Sluba,"
sort of a dplyr-like library.
So there are Python libraries
that are very much inspired
by the R counterparts.
You can adopt those.
You can get involved with those.
I don't think you're
going to have quite
the same end-to-end experience.
But you can, like I said, get
involved with the projects
that you do in Python, what
you loved so much about R,
and try to get those
more widely adopted.
Thank you.
I see.
Thanks, Jake, for
sharing the link
to Siuba there in the chat too.
Alan, I see some plus
ones to your question.
So I'd love to have you
jump in and ask that too.
Yeah, sure.
Hi.
My question is about
the impact that RStudio
has had on the community
over the years.
I think it's been really
positive in helping
the community be welcoming and
encouraging and open in a way
that I think folks agree, and
we make lots of jokes about,
was not necessarily
the way when I was
a grad student, for example.
Was that a conscientious
orientation?
I'm curious about
the story of how
you came to that kind of
contribution in particular
and how conscientious it was.
Yeah, I was very
conscientious.
I definitely think
a lot of us first
encountered the R community
in less friendly mood.
And I think that was
disappointing, like, wow, it'd
be great if more people felt
welcome and more people felt
like they could come in and
ask questions and succeed.
But I would credit, primarily,
Hadley for his orientation
around that.
For those of you
that know him or have
heard him talk about
this sort of stuff,
he is extremely passionate
about inclusiveness,
and friendliness,
and welcomingness.
I mean, there's a
lot of people here
who believe in those things.
But he really set
the tone for that
and for the whole community
and for the company.
It's definitely
very self-conscious.
That's great to hear.
It's really made an impact.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Paul, I see you have
your hand raised.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, sure.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
So I guess my question-- well,
this is kind of a question,
but it's also something
that having discussions
with my-- sorry, I'm
moving around the house.
I have my newborn daughter.
She was just born this
Saturday so I'm here like--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Congratulations.
--changing diapers
and everything, whatnot.
So I work for the
Panama Canal Authority.
And the Panama
Canal has recently
created a data-science unit.
And so basically,
we're 16 people there.
And I'm the only one
that is a heavy R
user because we're
divided, these like me
against the rest of the world.
It's not like [INAUDIBLE].
So we work in many
different projects.
And basically,
everybody else does
everything, like
machine-learning, and that sort
of thing, in Python.
And then I do my thing in
R. So my question would be,
how much--
I mean, there's always a debate.
And you always find
on the internet
these papers and
discussions, whether to use
R or Python for
machine-learning, for AI,
or whatever.
And I've seen all sorts
of opinions about it.
There's people
that it's like, OK,
Python is better when it comes
to AI and machine-learning.
And then R is better for
statistical computing
or for computational
statistics purposes.
Now, I'm an actuary.
And I've been using R since I
worked for insurance companies
in maybe 2006.
And this is probably
a testimonial also.
I've never had the
need to use Python.
I've used R for almost
all my life for doing
computational stats
and data analysis
and for [INAUDIBLE]
series and whatnot.
So my question would be,
in terms of its capability
of dealing with large
data sets, in terms
of its capability for modeling,
machine-learning purposes
and everything, how would you
say that R compares to Python?
Because that's
something I'm always
interested in knowing
because I'm a heavy R user.
And I'm not saying that Python--
I mean, Python, both are
wonderful tools for data
science and everything.
But to me, I'm at Justin Hopkins
University getting a master's
degree in data science.
And I try to use R
as much as I can.
I've been exposed to
Python, but still I
feel that statistical
analysis I think
is way easier with
R than with Python.
Yeah, definitely.
I would say statistical
analysis, interactive data
exploration, communicate,
creating data products that
communicate things, R
is better than Python
in all those things, I think.
It's not as widely
used as a language.
So it's not as general purpose.
And in terms of
large data sets, I
think mostly that is handled
by either external systems you
interface with or native
codes, or Dplyr or DataTable
or DuckDB or Arrow or Spark.
There's some means
by which you're
able to access large data.
It's not really confined
by the language.
And I think that our interfaces
to those technologies
are pretty comparable to Python.
I do think, in terms
of machine-learning,
there's a lot of
machine-learning packages in R.
And some of the most important
things, like XGBoost and stuff,
work very well in
R. We have created
deep-learning interfaces in R
both to TensorFlow and Torch.
But Python probably does have
an edge in deep-learning,
I would say, in that you
can use those libraries.
And there's probably
more extensions
to those things
that are available.
But deep-learning is one
part of machine-learning,
one part of working with data.
And it's not really predominant.
In some fields it's
really quite important,
but it's not really predominant.
So I think what we're
hoping to make easy
for our users is a world
where if you want to use R,
and it is so much easier
for so many things,
it's very easy for
you to make that case,
things like articulate
for interoperability,
things like that.
We're trying to make it
easy to make that case.
And so I would say like for
the things you're doing,
R is clearly better.
I could certainly see
where if someone says,
I'm using PyTorch, I like the
Python interface to PyTorch
better.
Sure.
Thank you.
Sorry, Paul.
I see so many
questions in the chat.
I just want to make sure
we get to those too.
But I see some great
recommendations in the chat
too.
And congrats again.
We love to send
you a onesie too.
So if you want a
DM me your address.
But Lisa, I see you
just asked a question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Would you want to jump in?
Sure.
So I was just wondering
about success cases
using Posit products
at companies.
I'll be honest.
I'm essentially trying to push
for getting something other
than RStudio Desktop at my job.
So what are some of the maybe--
if there's a single
success story
that you love to tell people
about or just some comment.
I would go to the--
and Rachael might have
better pointers here.
But we have quite a
few things written up
on our website about this.
So we go to the Posit website.
I don't know.
Rachel, what do you think
the best single destination
for that is?
We've written up a
lot of case studies.
For stories?
Yeah.
So I can copy the
link over for you.
But I would also recommend
the Champion site
that I built, I guess,
a few months ago.
It's still being updated
with the new Posit site,
so not every great resource is
there yet, but it is coming.
But I'll share those two
links in the chat with you.
I know, Lisa, you've
seen that before too.
Let's see.
Thank you, Hannah,
for helping with that.
But any other suggestions, J.J.?
And that would be my main--
Favorite stories?
Yeah, that would be
my main suggestion.
PK, I see you had
some guidance there.
Do you want to
weigh in for Lisa?
Oh, can't speak.
OK.
Well, there's some
great suggestion
there in the chat too.
And I appreciate everyone
sharing their experience.
So jumping over to
a Slido question.
Somebody had asked,
when do you know
is a good time to move
to a data-science role
based on your experience?
I may not be qualified
to answer that question.
This is about
data-science careers.
And I guess, I'm trying to
contextualize, this is--
move to a data-science
role from what?
So it's an anonymous question,
but I can try and guess.
I'm imagining.
So let's say this person
is a business analyst
and trying to make the
move to data science.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
I don't know.
It's very contextually
depending on organizations,
the organization that you're in
and what sort of data science
they're actually doing,
and what sort of folks
they like to hire, and how they
value different types of work.
So I don't know that I have
a good answer for that.
I see, Travis, you asked
a question in the chat
a little bit ago.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
Hey, J.J., a question about
building a successful business
on top of open source.
So a lot of us, probably
most of us here--
I myself am in pharma, so
no one talks to each other.
We all guard.
Our technical processing
code as is IP behind a closet
somewhere.
But there's momentum
going towards--
how do we do more open source?
And how do we start
to talk to each other?
And still grow and hire people
and do the opposite thing.
I suspect, there's
probably a virtuous cycle
shout out that you're going
to give, which is awesome.
I always love to
hear more about that.
But just kind of
key pieces of advice
for talking to CEOs,
talking to business leaders,
orgs, and convincing
at a high level
that this is the direction
that we should go and still
be sustainable as a business.
Being just a
technology vendor first,
it's a little different, because
you guys aren't a technology
vendor first.
I'm assuming you're work
in a pharma company.
And so you're trying
to figure out,
how can we create more
ground for collaboration
with other pharma companies
and the community?
That's right.
And I think there
you might make the case
that these sorts of
things enable everyone
to collectively move forward.
And then our core
competency is like--
we always think of
RStudio as the things
that are paid products or
things that you buy when you're
trying to adopt R at scale.
If you're an
individual, you rarely
would have need for
any of these things.
But it's like, oh, we're
an organization of hundreds
of people or dozens
of people, or we're
trying to deploy things
on the web securely,
and all that sort of thing.
So I think there's
the line there.
It's sort of at scale.
And so it's not exactly
the same reasoning chain.
But it is some kind of a
virtuous cycle thing, where
I think you need to make
the case that somehow
more collaboration with the
community and other companies
will create situations where
your core competency will
be more valuable.
I know that was one of
the rationales for Google,
when they open-sourced
TensorFlow.
They basically said, well,
were going to be really, really
good at training
TensorFlow models
and hosting TensorFlow models.
So if we get lots of
people using TensorFlow,
then that's good for us.
Or we get lots of
machine-learning researchers
using TensorFlow, then when
they come to work for us,
they already know TensorFlow.
And so I think there can be
things like that, where you're
creating a broader community.
You're creating network effects.
And your company then
is in a good position
to help people use
those things at scale.
I can think of like
Databricks has a thing called
ML Flow, which is like a
machine-learning experiment
management library.
I think their rationale--
I think they were
very clear about it.
They're like, this
is open source.
You can run it anywhere.
Anybody can run it on their
own machine, whatever.
But we think we're going to
be really good at hosting
machine-learning
workloads at Databricks,
so we think if more
people use this,
it's going to be easier for
them to eventually interact
with Databricks.
So there may be rationale
along those lines
in your particular industry.
Those are great examples.
Thanks so much.
Sure.
Thank you.
And, Lisa, I wanted to
add on to your question
too and just share
a helpful resource.
Sorry, sometimes it's hard
for me to hear the question
and look at the questions in
the chat at the same time.
But Tiger Tang, who
works at Carfax,
gave a great talk at
the RStudio conference
this year on saving
1,000 hours with RStudio.
And it was selling
R in your workplace.
But a big lesson
there was, like,
selling the power of automation
and a lot of the time saved.
So I would definitely recommend
checking out that talk too.
So jumping over to some of
the other questions here.
Let me jump up to
some from earlier.
One on Slido, J.J., was, how
does your usual day at work
look?
Any suggestions
for a middle-aged,
new-to-data-science career
trying to balance work
and life?
One of the things I try to
do is strictly segment my time,
so I have time
that I can just be
absorbed in solving
problems or writing
code or things like that.
And that time, I refuse to be
interrupted during that time.
I don't interleave
those kind of things
that require more concentration
and thinking with things
that are more transactional.
And so I might come to work.
And I might spend
four or five hours
working on various problems
that are in front of me.
And then I might
spend 45 minutes
looking at my email and
slack and just seeing,
has anyone been
trying to communicate
with me this morning?
How urgent are those things?
And then, similarly, I
might do the same thing
later on in the day.
I might say, OK, now I'm
going to do that again.
But I think not allowing
yourself to be interrupted
is really important.
And even if you're
currently going from a place
where you're interrupted
the whole day long
and you're constantly
trying to interleave
high-concentration things,
you might be getting like way
less done than you could.
And so even if you
say, well, my job
actually requires quite
a bit of interaction,
even if you could set aside--
I'm trying to set aside
six or seven hours
for a deep work every day.
If you could set
aside two or three,
or four or five, whatever
it is that you can manage,
that makes a big difference.
And I also try to be pretty--
There's lots of things that
you could do in your work
and in your job.
There's lots of things
that would be a good idea.
And I try to be really
choosy about what I actually
say, yes, we're going to do.
Because I feel if I say
yes to too many things,
then it's very
dilutive to the things
that really, really matter.
How do you find six to
seven hours of focus time
as the CEO with
all the meetings?
This is what I said earlier.
Maybe some of you may
have met Tareef Kawaf,
who's our president of RStudio.
He's been here for 10 years.
And that was our deal.
I said, I need to code
for seven hours a day.
So you got me for
as much as you need.
I'm your partner.
We can work whatever
issues we need to work.
I'm always here.
But it can't be a world
where I'm getting--
seven is like a
rough approximation,
but on any given
day, it might vary.
But I think it goes
back to being clear
like, OK, someone else needs
to be tending to those things.
Thank you.
Michael, I see you had asked
a question much earlier
about the company roadmap.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
I can jump in.
Hi, J.J..
I feel like I'm
talking to a celebrity
having been such an
RStudio fan, so I
appreciate you hopping on the
last call of the year here.
I was just curious, being such
a big fan of the R community,
what the roadmap looks like for
Posit, and maybe one-, three-,
five-year strategy
quick high level.
Well, I think on
the open source side,
you can see that we are trying
to make Quarto and Shiny
multi-language things.
On the modeling side, we have
some Python-oriented modeling
projects.
And we have tidy models.
So it's like TBD
how deep we're going
to go in terms of
Python-modeling,
but we certainly have a big
commitment to tidy models.
On the commercial product side,
our products now, I think,
they don't work together quite
as well as we'd like them to.
So I think kind of putting
the tea in Posit team,
making those products connect
in Workbench, and Desktop
and PackageManager all work
together really, really
well is important to us.
Integrating those things
with the other things
that people are doing in their
enterprise with data science
is really important to us.
Providing a cloud
version of those things
is really important
as well, letting
people maybe start using
the products in the cloud
and then move to on-prem
or VPC-based things,
or vise versa, just getting
the breadth of products
scaled to what the customer
is able to adopt and absorb.
And then I think
we actually see,
this as a newer thing,
a significant role
for our student academy in
providing learning experiences
that are really not superficial
and transactional, but really
deep.
And so we're pretty excited
about what we've done
with RStudio Academy so far.
And we'll be doing a
lot more with that.
So that's some of the
stuff that's on our mind.
Thank you.
Sure.
Eric, I see you just put a
question into the chat as well.
Do you want to jump in next?
Yes.
Hi, J.J..
I apologize for my voice,
getting over a nasty flu thing.
But while my voice
works here, I was
curious how you and your
various teams at Posit,
when you think about launching a
big initiative such as Corridor
or Shiny for Python, et cetera,
what are you using internally
or, what you can reveal, to
really quantify if that's
really being successful or not?
Because a lot of times when
I have ideas at the day job,
where I think we can
transform the way we operate
or the way we analyze
results, it always
comes back to leadership
teams saying, well, what's
the value you're giving us.
And that's a hard question
for me to answer sometimes.
I wonder how you approach those.
Well, I look at
those things like--
I always look at usage metrics.
And there's different
proxies for usage metrics.
Package downloads is one usage
metric that you have often.
And so I look at what's
the trend of usage?
Is it an accelerating trend?
So I don't know.
In absolute terms, if there's a
million downloads of the Shiny
package, I don't know if that's
a lot or little, actually,
because I don't know if most
people download it eight times
or--
So I look at
momentum of projects
and I see what the trend
line looks like over time
and, again, is it accelerating?
As a way of gauging, are we
having the impact that we want?
Or is it growing organically?
Is word of mouth leading
to more adoption?
So when I see projects that
are flat in their adoption,
I'm questioning, is that as
important as we thought it was?
Because if it's flat, it
means natural word of mouth
isn't growing it.
So that's, I think,
the best we can really
do is just look at
like adoption metrics
and how they grow over time.
Thank you.
And comparative
adoption metrics.
You go like, what are some
analogs to what we're doing?
OK, well, how do our
adoption metrics look like
compared to that analog?
Yeah, I do want to mention, at
least for having Posit connect,
the API does give us some
interesting metrics on, say,
Shiny app usage and
things like that.
So that's at least a start.
Yeah, and that's a
great thing to say.
Hey, look, we started
with this many users.
Look, it's like tripled.
So that's the most convincing
way to make the case, I think.
Great.
Thank you very much.
I see somebody else
had asked on Slido,
any advice on getting involved
with Posit's open-source
efforts, specifically in the
Shiny or machine-learning
areas?
Yep.
I mean, I'll tell
you we always welcome
people who get involved.
And in many cases,
we've ended up
hiring people who get really,
really involved in projects.
And then the first
way to get involved,
if you're just like, I'm
not comfortable making pull
requests or really trying
to understand the code,
is just like reporting
issues and making
PRs for documentation
and things like that.
So that's a first step
that's accessible to anyone.
But I think that a
really good repo-- and I
think some of the
tidyverse repos do this.
They will actually tag
their GitHub issues
with good first issue as a tag,
meaning if you're just got off
the bus, and you don't
know this project at all,
you don't know the code, this
could be a good first issue
for you to try to tackle.
And you can even go to
a repo and say, hey,
I see you guys don't have
any good first-issue tags.
Can you make some?
Because I'd like to
work on some issues.
I can tell you
that the people who
maintain those repos would
be very excited about someone
who says like, what are
some issues I can work on?
So I think working on
issues is a great way
to learn the tech,
start interacting
with the development team.
And really, the sky's the limit.
And if you really get involved
and really make contributions
and really interact, I
think you can do a lot.
Thank you.
I see lots of other anonymous
questions coming in here too.
And one was, there are lots of
options for teaching coding.
Have you thought about
developing something
for the younger generation
to begin learning R, like K
through 12?
We haven't.
I think that would be awfully
interesting if someone could
figure out how to do that well.
I mean, really,
what we've gone--
I have kids.
And I've seen them learn coding
with the various self-paced
online things.
One complaint I have would
be, you can learn some tricks.
And you can learn how to write
a loop, how to set a variable.
But you don't actually
learn how to do the work.
Because when you really
sit down and do the work,
you're really frustrated.
You have to learn
how to do research.
You have to learn how
to read error messages.
There's all this
stuff that is not
covered in these
sort of drilling
on these tactical skills.
So with RStudio Academy
we've gone the other way.
It's like, how can we have a
really thorough experience,
where people are
doing real projects,
and they have mentors,
and it's like real work.
So that's the kind of thing I'd
want to see for high schoolers.
You're actually doing real work.
You have a mentor, not
you're just like cargo
culting some tutorials.
And that's the easy--
it's easy to do the, hey, look,
self-paced tutorial learning.
But it doesn't actually
really, really get people
where they need to be.
Maybe some of the work
that we're doing in Academy
can eventually turn
into, hey, if you
want to teach a course in
high school on data science,
here's materials.
And here's an approach.
And here's a training
thing you can go to.
So maybe some of that will
lead in that direction.
Do you see Quarto helping to
fill the gaps between business
users and data scientists?
Yeah, I think
there's two ways.
So the focus that we have
on creating data products,
and not just data products
that are static, but like Shiny
applications or reports
that you can parameterize,
reports that you can
schedule, that is
a way to take the expertise,
knowledge, and skills of data
scientists and project
them in a flexible way
throughout the rest
of the organization.
So that's one piece, these
flexible, powerful, customized
bespoke data products.
And the other way is
to, I was saying before,
like through the
tidyverse, trying
to make people, who are
actually capable of quite
a bit of technical work, but
have never done programming,
to get them into a capacity
where they're actually
able to take a data set and do
some of their own exploration.
Frank, I see you had put
a question in the chat.
You want to jump in next?
Of course.
Hey, J.J..
Thanks for your answers so far.
I forget what response--
you were talking about,
you make sure that you
get your time for doing
the important work,
and you're focused
on that stuff.
And it reminded me of
a few of the podcasts
that I listened to and
the books that I've read.
And I'm curious if there's
anything on your radar
that you could recommend,
maybe I haven't heard of yet.
About that?
I haven't listened to a lot
of media about that topic.
So I don't think I have
any recommendations there.
How about just generally?
Generally?
I listen to some political
and social commentary stuff.
I rather listen to some
Magic the Gathering stuff.
Again, this is all pretty
particular flavored.
I don't know that I'd make
general recommendations from.
Let me think.
I will say that.
It goes back a little bit to
the question about ChatGBT.
There is one
organization in podcasts
that I do listen to,
that I do recommend.
There's an organization
called the Center
for Humane Technology.
And they have a podcast.
In the '80s and '90s, everyone
was a techno optimist,
like the more tech the better.
And then we've seen
in the last 10 years
how tech that's
developed unreflective
and not adequately
understood by its creators,
regulated by government,
can lead to some very, very
unpleasant consequences.
So the Humane Tech Podcast
covers some of that ground.
So I recommend that.
Looks awesome.
I appreciate it.
Yep, that's the podcast.
Awesome.
I thought you might also
recommend The Chaos Machine.
I know that was
one that came up.
And that's when
I recommended--
And that, actually, I got
from the Humane Tech Podcast.
There's a very, very good book
called The Chaos Machine which
is about--
you can probably all mostly
guess what The Chaos Machine.
It's modern social media
and how it got that way,
and what we might be
able to do about it.
A few other
anonymous questions.
One was, your company has
some really great people,
Hadley, Jenny, so many others.
Did you recruit them?
Or did these people
just find you?
I would say more on the find.
It's more like we just
have maintained a lot
of relationships over time.
And then, sometimes, that
relationship evolves into,
hey, you could work here.
What would that look like?
It's more just like a
natural conversation
that happens than a specific
recruiting, I would say.
I see, Jeff, you had asked
a question a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in next?
Sure.
Thanks for the invite today.
Thanks for stopping by, J.J..
Really appreciate it.
Been a user of RStudio
products, Posit products now,
the Enterprise Solutions,
for about five years.
But as things progress
in the data space,
getting a little bit
more decentralized,
I guess you could say,
I guess that brings me
to this question.
Is there anything
on the Posit roadmap
to make analysis of
Web3 data, blockchain
data, and decentralized data
sources a little bit easier?
I don't know.
There's probably packages
that people are working on.
You're probably
more aware of than I
am to make analyzing this
sort of data possible.
So there's our packages.
There's Python packages.
I don't know of anything
in our offerings
or product strategy that are
specifically targeted at that.
If anybody has
package recommendations,
feel free to share
them in the chat too.
OK.
Thank you.
Let me check over to make
sure there weren't questions
from you all that I missed.
I do see quite a few
others on Slido too.
I want to make sure I ask them.
All of them that were
in the Zoom chat.
But one on Slido was, what is
your relationship with R core
development team?
So a bunch of us have
known a bunch of people
on the R core development
team for quite a while.
I think Hadley's known people
on the R core team for 20 years.
I've known a bunch of folks
on the team for over 10 years.
So we are colleagues
in that way.
We know each other.
Sometimes there's
technical collaboration.
We don't have actually anyone
in the company who's on R core.
But we have some folks
that do quite a bit,
Lionel Henry comes
to mind, folks
that do quite a bit of
communication with them,
provide patches, work on
stuff collaborating with them.
But we don't have-- that's
entirely its own entity.
I would characterize our
relationship as collegial.
We've got our stuff
we're working on.
And they've got their
stuff they're working on.
And there's intersection.
And we try to work
together to make things
work as well as they
can when things come up
that need to be resolved or
run aground or sorted out.
We had a few times, when we've
had to really work together
on something to get it right.
And we've had a good
experience doing that.
There was a question
earlier that I had
missed that was around VS code.
And, Sam and Allen,
thank you for helping,
bring it to my attention.
It was, with many
useful new extensions,
VS Code is an alternative
that a lot of R programmers
are switching to.
Where do you see R
pseudo IDE in five years?
Well, I do think that VS
code is an incredibly powerful
but opinionated text-editing
programmers tool.
So I think if you're willing
to put the time into learning
it and customizing it, and
learning how to drive it,
getting all your
extensions dialed,
it's really powerful
and really great.
RStudio has a
different philosophy.
RStudio has much more
of an opinionated,
these are the tools
you're going to need
to do data analysis, presented
in a unified, clear, hopefully,
straightforward and simple way.
So it's actually trying
to do something different
than VS code is.
VS code is trying to be a
maximally powerful extensible
programmer's editor.
So I think it's possible to
get with various extensions.
And we have our Quarto
extension for VS Code.
We're definitely doing a
lot of work with VS code
for people who want that
environment of like,
I'm controlling everything.
And I'm composing my IDE out
of all these different parts.
And I'm customizing
and configuring.
Great.
But I actually think that many,
many, many data scientists need
something that's more
straightforward and
streamlined.
And that's kind of
where RStudio fits.
TJ, I see your
question in the chat
that I used to
sometimes get when
I was working at conferences.
And somebody had just asked,
didn't Microsoft buy RStudio?
No.
Yeah, they brought Revolution.
Yeah, they bought a company
called Revolution Analytics.
Yes.
Another Slido question
was, thoughts to introduce
a Posit-consulting arm?
Imagine there are many small-
and mid-sized businesses that
could benefit from data science
but don't have the resources.
It comes up from time to time.
I think that our
approach to consulting--
one of the tricky
things about consulting
is that to grow a
consulting business,
you have to hire
a lot of people.
And so to grow a significant
consulting business,
you might need to hire
hundreds of people.
And that in and of itself
creates a lot of challenges,
like managing an organization
of hundreds of people.
So we've tended to be more
on the building-a-product
organization, which can
be smaller, doesn't demand
so much hiring for growth, and
try to find partners that are
growing consulting businesses.
And some of them are larger.
And some of them are smaller.
Some of our best partners
are 5, 10, 15, 20 people.
And some of them aspire
to be bigger than that.
And some of them are
happy being smaller.
But so we've wanted to scale
that presence through partners,
rather than do it ourselves.
Thank you.
And Marlene, good call.
I know it's helpful to paste the
Slido questions into the chat
too.
Hannah or Robert, you could
help me in the back background
with some of those, when we're
talking about them as well.
Actually, I can do this copy
this one over right now.
Question from
earlier on Slido was,
do you have any advice for
fellow data-science leaders
on building and
maintaining a great team,
making a big positive
impact in a business?
I probably don't have
great advice about that.
I know when I've worked in
very large organizations,
you do have to promote yourself.
Lots of people
need to understand
the value of what you're doing.
And I imagine that's
a big part of thriving
as a data-science team
inside a bigger environment.
I think probably finding
the people for whom
you can add a lot of
value and initiating work
with them is a
good way to build.
You want to have stakeholders
that are outside of your group
really excited about what
you're doing and trying to help
you grow what you're doing.
So some of the times, you
have to go find those people
in the organization.
Definitely.
Thank you.
Another question over on Slido.
And then any questions that
I have missed from anybody
as we get to the
top of the hour,
feel free to raise your hand
on Zoom here as well, or just
re-copy it into the chat.
But one was, what would
be the personality profile
of an ideal Posit tech employee?
It's interesting.
I don't know.
I would say, one of the
most important attributes
would be, I would say,
humility about what
you know and don't know.
So even if you are really
smart and knowledgeable
and capable to not walk into
situations, where you're
collaborating, where
you bring that,
to have the amateur's
mindset of like,
I don't know what the answer is.
Let's see if we can
figure it out together.
I think that's the vibe of
technical collaboration here.
And that's not always the vibe
of technical collaboration
in companies.
Sometimes, it's like
strong personality
versus strong personality.
And I would say we very
much don't have that.
So that's one attribute.
But beyond that, I
mean, we have people
who love to go give
talks and be on Twitter.
And we have people
who just don't ever
want to have anyone talk to
them about anything ever.
You know, so there's a huge
variety of personality types
for folks that work here.
And we try to find a
place for all of them.
Thank you very much.
I don't see any other
questions that were
coming to mind that I missed.
So I'm going to go back
over to some of the Slido
ones for the last minute here.
But I also want to
remind everybody,
because we were talking about
the topic of self promotion.
In the beginning
when I was asking
if you do have any feedback
about the Data Science
Hangout and things that
you'd like to see next year,
I wanted to make
sure I don't forget
to share the survey with you.
So let me just copy
that over there too.
Thank you.
Another question over here on--
this is not a question,
but a comment.
So thank you, J.J., for leading
Posit and helping me avoid
SPSS years ago in grad school.
Good.
Oh, I see Andy.
You just asked a question.
I'll let you jump in first.
Hi.
So Posit is a B-Corporation,
a benefit corporation.
And I'm wondering if you
have anything to share, aside
from public benefit of bringing
this open-source tool to all
of us that use it
for free, anything
else around environmental or
the benefit corp structure?
I mean, the biggest
differentiating characteristic
of public benefit
corporations is that they are,
unlike traditional C Corps--
the evolution of C Corps
in the United States
and the case law and
things, have made C Corps--
they're pretty much exclusively
beholden to their shareholders
as the stakeholder that matters.
The biggest thing
about B Corp is
it changes the corporate
law and corporate charter,
so that your stakeholders
are considered more broadly,
your customers, your
employees, your community,
the environment, your
shareholders, all stakeholders.
And your duty is
to run the company
for the benefit of
all stakeholders
and to balance their
concerns and interests.
So that's the main thing.
And then, the way the
law works is you also
establish a public
benefit that you're
accountable to working towards.
In our case, it's
open-source software.
We actually get rated by
the B-Lab every three years.
And if you go look
at our report,
there's quite a bit in
there about sustainability,
environmental sustainability.
And a bunch of the
points come from that.
And we're actually
about to get rerated.
So there'll be a new report
coming out next spring,
hopefully by February or
March, that actually goes
into more depth about that.
But if you look at our
current benefit year report,
you'll see the different things
that we've done and are doing.
J.J., do you have a meeting
you're going to go run
to in one minute here?
Or do you have one more minute?
Actually-- no, it's fine.
There is another meeting going
on that I'm supposed to be at.
But if we run over a
minute or two, that's fine.
OK.
Thank you.
One question that
I did miss earlier
was, what areas
do you anticipate
Posit growing and any
career opportunities
opposite in these areas?
Well, one area of
significant growth that
has occurred over the last
years is, like I said,
we've been firing up
the Posit Academy.
And we've hired
quite a few people
as educators in that group.
So if that continues
to go well, I
think we'll definitely
be growing there.
And then, I would say
that the Posit business
model and balance between open
source and commercial software,
I think we've sorted
out pretty well.
And so I think that the
growth of the company
will look approximately
like it is now.
So we have I think
something like 42% or 43%
of our engineers work
on open-source software.
And then a bunch of others
work on commercial software.
So in software
development, there's
opportunities that are
both in open source.
And the best way to, by the
way, get hired into open source
is to be an open-source
contributor.
I would say, there's almost no
one in our open-source group
that just like applied as
like, I'm a software engineer.
I'd like to do open
source at Posit.
It was all people that
literally, were actually
already doing
open-source software
and actually collaborating
with us on GitHub, et cetera.
And then we said, oh,
yeah, it'd be great.
We should work together.
So that's that.
And then lots of opportunities
in sales and marketing
and things like that that
you'll see on our website.
Thank you, J.J..
I'm seeing a lot of
comments in here.
And this says,
J.J. For president,
so something to
think about here.
One last question.
Thank you, Jonathan, for
the great question here.
What are some
failures that you have
learned from in your career?
And how have you grown
from your experience?
I'd say one failure was the
second company that I started.
The first company I
started went pretty well.
And I thought that, oh, the
skill that I was applying there
was like--
how do I want to say this?
Coming up with brand-new ways
to work and brand-new ideas
is a skill.
And then that's what
startup founders do.
And I, in my second
company, tried
to create a whole bunch
of brand-new things,
like, oh, re-imagine
your work this way.
Do this totally different
thing that you're doing now.
And that didn't go very well.
And I took from that,
it's much better
to be rooted in what you observe
people exactly what they're
doing and try to
make that better.
So as an example, when
I started working in R,
I wasn't a data scientist.
I wasn't an R programmer.
And we easily could
have said, OK, we're
going to reimagine how you work
with R. We're going to build
this brand new interface.
Forget about the console.
Forget about it.
But I said, well,
there's lots of people
using R just this way.
And so if I can just
make that better,
then that's a good foundation.
So I think overreaching
in product design
is something that I definitely
paid for in the second company
that I started.
And I've tried to not do that.
Try to stay close to
what people are doing.
I think I alluded
to this before,
but not knowing yourself
well and finding yourself
with responsibilities
and a work situation
where you're not being
nourished the way you need to,
you can end up in that spot.
And it's very hard to
dig yourself out of it.
That's happened to me.
Thank you.
I know I said that
was the last question.
But I don't want
to end on failure.
I know something we
talk about at Posit
is creating a company
that's around in 100 years.
What do you think is one of the
most important lessons learned?
Or things that you're
thinking about to get us
to 100 years from now.
Well, I think the
number one thing
was get the right
corporate structure,
so all the incentives
are aligned,
so that's the only thing
we need to worry about.
And we're not worried
about maximizing
some short-term objective.
So that's one.
Now, two is going to
be leadership succession.
So it's easy to
get caught up in,
oh, hey, there's four
or five of us that
are kind of leading things.
And we're making it all work.
And then, but we're
all going to get old.
And so trying to figure out over
time who are the people that
are going to succeed you and
giving them opportunities
to even accelerate their
learning and bring them
into the space
that you're in is,
I think, where a
lot of organizations
fail to be sustainable.
They may be like
economically sustainable,
they may have the right
corporate incentives.
But then succession
does them in.
So it's not like
right on our doorstep,
but it's something that's
on my mind to think about.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, J.J., for
joining us today and sharing
your experience.
My pleasure.
This has been really fun.
And thank you all for being
a part of the Data Science
Hangout today.
If this was your first one, or
for the past year and a half,
or however long we've
been doing this,
thank you for coming to
spend time with us all.
I hope you and your families
have a wonderful holiday
season and happy new year.
This is our last
Hangout for 2022.
But we will be back here after
a bit of a holiday break.
So we'll be back on
Thursday, January 12
for the first Hangout of 2023.
Thank you all so much for making
this the best part of the week.